You know,
when you get off of like,
you had like one of the most
spectacular fights with Jon Jones,
I mean down to the wire,
like is as close as it gets and when
you get out of a fight like that,
will you all most won the title against
the greatest of all time? Like what is,
what is that feeling like and
where do you go from there?
Uh, you know, uh, it was tough.
It was really tough because I
know everybody was saying like,
you're winning this fight, winning this
fight. You had three rounds against him.
Are you winning this fight tonight?
If it felt like, like you said,
it was something, it was just, it was just
right there at the goal line. You know,
I didn't really pass that
goal nine at all. Um,
I just felt like I knew it
was tough. It was tough, but,
but, but like now I'm sitting here
now talking to you. It's a big,
it's a really good experience for
me. And, and you know, I really,
it's a good time for me.
If I was a w e is a highlight in my
career for sure in my life for sure.
Well,
it's such a close fight when the,
when the scorecards are being
tagged and you, uh, you know,
you're just sitting there waiting for
the decision. Did you think you hadn't,
you know, I didn't know. Right. I
didn't know. I didn't know much chaos.
Could you even remember what had happened
over the last five rounds? I remember,
I remember, I remember the, I
remember the fight, uh, and I got,
I remember almost the whole fight, but it
was just John. John's just such a basis.
He, I'm telling you, just
for me, John Jealous,
winning over John Jones is bigger than
taking the belt. I'm filling that guys.
The guy is such a beast and, and uh, yeah.
What was the question?
No, it's okay. Being Express yourself.
That's fine. I mean, I agree with you.
He is a beast.
You know,
I'm very disappointed with all the
stuff that's happened to him obviously,
and especially the most recent one,
which I really,
I really believe based on the
evidence as a mistake, I think,
I think he got ahold of something
tainted because of they,
they tested him before
that he was negative.
They tested him after that he was negative
and what he tested for with such a
minuscule amount, there's no way it was
something that he, yeah, there's no way,
like according to Novitsky and according
to Usada according to like how they
test people, what, whatever he consumed,
it must have been an
extremely small amount.
It wasn't an amount that would have
had any benefit whatsoever in terms of
performance,
performance enhancing.
Well they know their thing. So,
you know, just let the, you know,
expert handled that.
I don't know what to say.
I know for a fact that he's been in
that same situation a couple of times.
This is not the first time.
So
he definitely is a wild motherfucker.
Hayes Hayes.
He definitely does some Shitty, probably
shouldn't do but a hundred percent man.
But, uh, I mean, but the thing is, it's
so stupid because he's, what is he?
He's the best guy, pound
for pound out there.
He's done things nobody
else has done is he,
he's just a beast and still
shit just comes up all the time.
He doesn't even need that steroids.
He doesn't even need that shit in them.
He's still the best out there. I don't
think he took anything. I really don't,
but I, but I agree with you on that.
And I think you need a guy like that.
You need a guy like that out there.
Like to bring you to your full potential.
Do you agree? Yeah, I agree with you.
I agree with you. Yeah. No. Like I said
to you, fighting him and beating him,
that's bigger than taking the bumps right
now. That's how I feel. Because he's,
look what it did to DC, man. Yeah.
And do you see is tough history that he
finished DC? Yes. That's just insane.
It's just insane.
And he finished him with a kick that DC
said he's never going to hit him with.
Yeah. That's crazy. That's insane. Yeah.
You Never gonna hit me with that
left thigh kick. Oh, blam yeah.
Just look for the opportunity to
fix it. Yeah. Tendencies are crazy.
It's just some of them just get so
ingrained in the way your body moves.
No, he's, he, he's an expert at what,
of course, what he's doing. And he's,
he's studying his opponent very well.
Uh,
everything is just such planet in
details for the fights and he just,
he knows exactly when he should
go for that or that or that.
And staying creative and use news fantasy.
And it's amazing to see.
Yeah. That Jackson Winkeljohn team
is truly exceptional team. I mean,
they really did do phenomenal with him.